today the traveler on the Nile enters a
Wonderland at whose Gates rise the
Colossal pyramids of which he has had
Visions perhaps from earliest childhood
Sosa the Great American archaeologist
egyptologist and historian Dr James
Henry breasted
Egypt is the land of pyramids Great and
Small what child isn't fascinated by
their towering Majesty they dot the
landscape of Egypt and number by most
recent count well over a hundred
for over a thousand years the pyramid
was the dominant form of Royal burial in
Egypt
did the Egyptians build pyramids for
this we need to delve into ancient
Egyptian religious myths of creation
in one myth a mound of Earth rose out of
the Primeval Waters
at the top of the mound a lily bloomed
as the first life form
the sun rose from its petals to bring
life to the newly created world
this mound took the concrete form of a
pyramided stone
the Egyptians called it Ben Ben a name
derived from the root word Ben that
means to rise up
also derived from this root word is the
word weeben which means the rising of
the Sun
so from the very beginning the pyramid
shape represented New Life emerging from
a mound of Earth bringing the sun rises
light and warmth
the Mount of creation was also the very
power of life itself
so it's not surprising that the ancient
Egyptians translated the mound into a
pyramid for Royal burials
pyramid embodied and symbolized creation
and Resurrection
Kings gave their Royal pyramids names
like the Horizon of Khufu or sneferu is
rising phrases that evoked the sun's
Ascension
the pyramid acted as a resurrection
machine for the king
now the pyramid burial didn't appear
overnight it gradually developed
the earliest King sunk their tombs into
the desert of abidos now bidos was the
cult Center of ancient Egypt's primary
funary god Osiris
these tombs had interior rooms lined
with mud brick to hold the king's body a
wooden Shrine and Grave Goods
the burial was crowned by a mound shaped
tumulus that symbolized the Primeval
mound of Resurrection
and protected the tomb below from
erosion
the funary enclosure in which the king's
Cults was celebrated was built closer to
the cultivation
in the second Dynasty Kings moved their
burials to Sakara the necropolis near
the Egyptian capital of Memphis
these tombs had multiple corridors cut
into the Rock no superstructure remained
although egyptologists assume the
burials were topped with mud brick or
stone mastabas mastaba means bench in
Arabic with sloping sides and a flat top
King zosure took it one step further he
laid one mastaba on top of the other and
integrated the king's funery enclosure
in one large structure
the result was the first step Stone
pyramid fill in the steps and you have a
true pyramid
I'll discuss these steps in depth when
we look at the pyramid complexes of
King's zosure and snuff room
then comes the inevitable question how
were the Pyramids built
believe it or not there is really no
simple answer to this question so let's
start with the basics what do you need
to create a pyramid
first you need a site with a broad
Bedrock foundation on which to build
something pyramid Builders learned by
trial and error
you also need a source of stone to
Quarry nearby
you need high ranking officials to
oversee pyramid construction people like
Architects priests and scribes with
administrative and building experience
and you need laborers to work year round
young Egyptian men probably registered
in their villages to be drafted into the
Royal pyramid project
imagine the amazement of a teenager from
a small agricultural Hamlet he arrives
at the building site and sees thousands
of men cutting and Hauling Stone and
then he views for the very first time a
massive pyramid rising in the background
it must have looked like a Cecil B
Demille production
laborers on Royal pyramid projects were
not slaves huge Public Work projects
like the pyramid building provided room
and board for workers
workers slept in dormitories on law
platforms they ate well
a study of animal bones in the Giza
workman's Village showed workmen
devoured large quantities of meat foul
and fish
huge bakeries Made bread
workers drank bone broth in enormous
amounts of beer
they received proper medical attention
skeletal remains show broken bones were
set and healed correctly
less encouraging was the presence of
spinal stress consistent with hard labor
pyramid towns were populated by
Craftsmen Farmers butchers Physicians
and guards priests both men and women
served the community
scribes administered the day-to-day
movement of people and goods princes and
high-ranking officials governed the
towns and lived in large villas nearby
upon arrival egyptologists assume
laborers were placed in divisions of
2000 workers
each division was split into two groups
of a thousand composed of five gangs of
200 workers each gang was further
divided into five files of 40 workers
at the Giza Pyramids files had names
like friends of King Khufu one of my
favorites was called the drunkards of
King menkaure
workers rotated in and out of many gangs
during their draft period how much time
they served in total we simply don't
know
how many laborers did it take to build a
pyramid let's take the Great Pyramid of
Khufu at Giza
most egyptologists believe khufu's
pyramid took 23 to 27 years to build
that means 340 Limestone blocks needed
to be quarried every day and every hour
34 blocks had to be delivered
according to calculations an entire
division of 2000 workers quarried and
transported stone blocks
for their 1 000 Men set the blocks and
courses there were also support people
like Craftsmen to make and repair copper
tools coryman kitchen and storeroom
staff Etc
all told as many as 20 000 people
contributed to the work on the Great
Pyramid
Not only was the Great Pyramid of feat
of engineering but it was also an
administrative accomplishment
now to build a pyramid you need tools
for stone cutting pounding cleaving
drilling sawing trimming and polishing
during the Great Pyramid age workers
used dolarite Hammer stones and copper
chisels with wooden hammers to cut the
limestone
if you look carefully you can still find
dolarite balls around the bases of some
pyramids
to cut harder Stones like Granite the
builders used a wet slurry of quartz
sand and metal saws
all of these methods were incredibly
labor intensive and time consuming yet
the ancient Egyptians excelled in
working with stone
after the Old Kingdom they used bronze
tools which were harder than copper
highly skilled pyramid Builders use
techniques like measuring and setting
points many pyramids are oriented to the
cardinal points East-West North and
South
ancient texts call the circumpolar Stars
the imperishable ones because they
neither rise nor set as they Circle the
celestial North Pole at 23 degrees
ancient Egyptian religion believed the
king's Eternal Destiny was to join these
Stars upon death the East was the place
of the Rising Sun and eternal
Resurrection
how did The Architects Orient the
pyramid to the cardinal points
there are many ideas that include
measuring the rising and setting points
of certain circumpolar stars or the
North Star the simplest and easiest
method was proposed by engineer Glenn
Dash an MIT trained engineer and
archaeologist who studied the pyramids
it involves plotting the sun's path
through the day using the shadow it
casts from a rod or pole stuck
vertically into the ground
as the sun moves through the sky the
shadow shifts across the floor like the
point on sundial
if you plot the Shadow's position on the
ground every half an hour you're left
with a curved Shadow line
with a curved Shadow line drawn you wrap
a short taut piece of string around the
vertical pole and move it around the
pole in a circle
the end of the string should intercept
two points on the shadow line
drawing a new line through these two
points creates a line running east and
west
to find the true north simply bisect the
East-West line
now if you do this on the day of the
Autumn Equinox it's possible to create a
perfectly straight Shadow line that runs
precisely East-West with no need for the
second string line why the equinox
the day is halfway between the summer
and the winter solstices so day and
night are of equal length meaning the
sun is perfectly centered in the sky
so let's say this is what the Egyptian
Architects did now the lines would need
to be extended outwards more than 755
feet roughly the size of Two and a Half
football fields
the slightest inaccuracy would increase
the angle of error then they would
measure one side of the pyramid base and
turn a right angle to make the corners
finally they would measure the
perpendicular sides to the opposite
corners and turn another set of right
angles the surveyors probably did this
by sight because any errors would be
averaged out
once the measuring of the base was
finalized workers cut small holes into
the Rock for a cord run through the
stakes if you look close enough around
the base of Khufu or cough race pyramid
you might well see the small holes for
posts that carry the cord
space less than around two inches apart
then the base of the pyramid needed to
be leveled
the ancient Egyptians used a level
square a right angled isosceles triangle
made from wood
this tool was in the shape of the letter
a and looked like a triangle ruler or a
builder's Square
a Plumb line was suspended from the top
of the a
when the plumb bob coincided with a mark
in the middle of the Cross Beam the
surface area on which the two legs stood
was level
to establish an equal level over a large
surface the triangle was laid on top of
a horizontal beam and calibrated
by fixing upon a leveling staff in the
distance differences in height could be
noted and corrected
actual field tests show it would
correctly level distances up to 90
meters
Builders use the same method to level
the platform of the pyramid
by placing the two feet of the A-frame
on the surface the plum registered any
deviation from horizontal
the stone was carved and measured again
until the plumb bob was centered on the
crossbar
the square level allowed The Architects
to keep the pyramid courses perfectly
horizontal
some archaeologists think that the
Egyptians dug a grid of channels that
covered the pyramid's base area and then
filled them with water
once the water's surface was marked on
the trench's sides the water was drained
and the channels were cut to a standard
depth
now most egyptologists today believe
this leveling method was not used mainly
because the water would evaporate during
the long Trek from the Nile to the
pyramid building site in the hot desert
now it's time to build the Pyramid
pyramids of the third Dynasty were
constructed in vertical layers that were
inclined inwards
in the early fourth Dynasty pyramids
Rose in horizontal layers with shaped
casing stones
later pyramids had rough Stone cores
filled out by backing Stones covered
with casing
and Middle Kingdom pyramids had mud
brick cores with a fine Limestone casing
all Kingdom pyramids were built with
different types of stones core Stones
placed horizontally in tears or steps
that got smaller towards the top backing
stones of many sizes that fill out the
space between the core stones and the
casing stones and large fine white
Limestone casing that creates a true
pyramid
the core Stones were so irregular that
the builders used significant quantities
of gypsum mortar to set them
if you look at the holes or any damage
to a pyramid you get a window into the
structure's guts and see these three
types of stones
how did the ancient Egyptians Hall Stone
sum as heavy as two tons from the Quarry
to the pyramid site
they did this by using tracks of wooden
planks arranged to form rails sunk into
a bed of limestone chips and desert clay
or plaster
a large Stone could be tumbled by a rope
lasso into a wooden sled with rounded
skids at the front
10 or 12 men could easily pull a two-ton
block on a sled up an inclined ramp
equipped with partially sunken wooden
planks
water was poured under the sled at the
front to reduce the friction
the form of incline pyramid delivery
ramps is one of the most hotly debated
questions today among egyptologists
Architects and engineers
only a few small pyramids have remains
of ramps many theories about so let's
take a look at the current theories
first is the single straight on-ramp
this ramp would need to be lengthened
each time the pyramid Rose to maintain a
gradual slope of one unit of Rise per 10
units of length
a slope of 8 degrees would make it
impossible for workers to drag the
stones up the ramps
the problem with the straight on ramp
theory is that work would stop when the
ramp needed to be lengthened
at the top of the pyramid the ramp would
be over a mile long and cover the Quarry
that provided the pyramid blocks
the sheer volume of stone needed for
this ramp would also exceed the volume
of stones needed to build the Pyramid
itself for these reasons the single
straight on ramp theory is not generally
accepted
another theory suggests a ramp that
zigzagged across one face of the pyramid
the problem here is that the ramp would
be too narrow to allow for two groups to
use the ramp simultaneously one going up
and the other going down also
maneuvering large blocks around a 90
degree Corner would require Levering
which is a really slow process
the wraparound ramp theory proposes a
spiral ramp around the structure of the
pyramid
one long Stone ramp accessed the Quarry
and Rose along one side of the pyramid
two-thirds of the way up the ramp
spiraled around to the top
however the wraparound ramp would
obscure large parts of the structure so
that an accurate measurement of the
pyramid's edges could not be taken
the zigzag ramp only goes up on one side
so it'd be easier to take measurements
the multi-delivery ramp theory is
dependent on the idea that the core of
each pyramid was stepped
blocks could be delivered by a series of
short ramps until the pyramid Rose high
enough to create additional ramps on the
higher side and so on
with this method a stone block would
follow a complicated course with lots of
twists and turns and 90 degree angles
the latest Theory limited to the Great
Pyramid
proposes an internal ramp that spiraled
up and around like a parking garage in
the inside of the core step pyramid
at the beginning of construction a
single external ramp was used to set the
largest Granite blocks for the king's
chamber
once a third of the work was completed
the ramp was replaced by an internal
structure that wrapped around the
pyramid at a slope of seven degrees
openings were left at the corners to
allow enough room to turn the blocks
around the corners
now the scan pyramids Mission used muons
to scan the Great Pyramid muons are
byproducts of the cosmic rays that form
in the earth's upper atmosphere and can
actually penetrate Stone
the muon scan did not show the presence
of any internal ramps within the Great
Pyramid
there are problems with all of these
theories
turning a two and a half ton Stone
around a 90 degree corner of a pyramid
is one and it's not easy
Mark later suggests that workers could
easily turn a block by tying a rope
around it and placing a smooth Rock
underneath the stone as a fulcrum
as you walk it across you stick another
fulcrum Stone under the other end and
you walk it further
it only takes twice the width of the
block to turn it and a tenth of the
weight of the block this makes 90 degree
turns of a two and a half ton block on a
spiral ramp a lot easier to do
another problem is that space was too
limited for the ramps at the very top of
the pyramid so how was the pyramidian or
the Capstone of the pyramid placed
in this case we look at Herodotus who
wrote that blocks at the top were lifted
with wooden levers Levering could be
used for side movements final
adjustments and to place the blocks on
uppermost courses
egyptologists of course continued to
debate this as well
so the search for answers about the type
of pyramid delivery ramp continues
now I've covered how the core Stones
were delivered and placed but how is the
fine white Limestone outer casing
beveled and placed to create a true
smooth side pyramid
in 2013 French egyptologist Pierre talei
made an exciting Discovery at the Red
Sea port of Wadi jarf he found a number
of papyri one of which belonged to an
inspector named mirror
mirror detailed the day-by-day movements
of his file that delivered stones from
the Eastern Quarry of coutura to the
Great Pyramid of Khufu
Mara's Journal noted that fine white
Torah Limestone was ferried to Giza by
means of wooden barges that sailed
through a series of canals
egyptologist Mark laner suggests the
builders used a water transport
infrastructure that took advantage of
the Nile flood
now from August to October at this time
the Nile Rose 23 feet
pyramids built on high plateaus took
advantage of the flood as a hydraulic
lift for 15 to 17 ton blocks
once offloaded the casing Stones were
hauled on wooden sleds to the pyramid
the casing stones at the base of the
Great Pyramid of Khufu display one of
the most remarkable Feats of stone
carving in the world
kufas stonemasons fitted together 7 to
15 ton blocks of stone with joints so
fine that not even a razor blade can
slip between them
how did the Egyptians achieve this
amazing feat
when the builders began the pyramid's
foundation pavement and the bottom
course of the casing they set the
cornerstones and several Center stones
on each face to establish the line
in the Quarry Stone Cutters dressed only
the bottom of the stone to fit precisely
with the rock below it
the stone was then hauled to its
intended place on the pyramid once
placed the side joint faces of the stone
were dressed so they fit the neighboring
Stone
the slope was marked on the joint face
and moved to life flush with its
neighbor Stone now the upper face was
labeled
part of the stone was still overhanging
the stone course beneath
where the two neighboring Stones touched
each other extra stock on the front of
the block was beveled away from the
slope line
The Unfinished stock was left like this
to help anchor the stone delivery ramps
that rose with the pyramid
once the pyrimidian was placed the
Masons dressed the extra stock on the
front of the block working from the top
of the pyramid down as they removed the
delivery ramps
they chipped away the excess Stone on
the pyramid face so that the spaces
between each block would gradually close
when the joint was so small a knife
blade could not slip between the joins
the Masons knew they could not cut any
deeper into the stone they had reached
the desired plane of the pyramid face
last but definitely not least the
builders needed to take into account the
pyramid's interior rooms and corridors
burial Chambers in most pyramids were
sunk or partly sunk into the Bedrock the
early Egyptians believed that the king's
rebirth occurred in the earth's depths
but by the fourth Dynasty the deep
underground funeral Chambers were
abandoned now they were placed higher
sometimes at ground level and oriented
East-West
by the time of Khufu the chamber sat
higher up in the pyramid so Builders
left openings as the pyramid Rose course
by course
the Royal burial chamber was oriented
East-West and the ascending Corridor
that met it ran north south
these orientations symbolize two views
of the pharaoh's afterlife
the east to west orientation related to
the sun cult and the King's place in it
the Pharaoh was the Earthly
manifestation of the sun god literally
the son of Wrath
in death the king would join the
East-West course of the Sun and be
eternally renewed
now pyramid corridors inside ran north
to south
from the burial chamber the passage
ascended to open on the Northern face of
the pyramid
it was believed upon death the pharaoh's
Soul would join with the circumpolar
stars of the northern sky as I mentioned
earlier these stars were known by the
ancient Egyptians as the imperishable
ones because they never sank into the
horizon
a number of structures accompanied the
pyramid all dedicated to the Eternal
Cult of the king
a mortuary Temple a budded the pyramid
with a Causeway connecting it to the
valley Temple and the port below
a satellite pyramid sat on the south of
the main pyramid along other subsidiary
pyramids for the King's family
all enclosed by a wall
the causeway ran from below from the
land of the living in the East to the
realm of the Dead above in the West
these structures made up the classic
pyramid complex
Middle Kingdom pyramids followed Old
Kingdom models but were much smaller
many Middle Kingdom pyramids were
constructed with mud brick cores faced
with limestone
Dieter Arnold an ancient Egyptian
architecture expert has estimated that
around 5 000 workers could build a mud
brick pyramid 246 feet high
this includes roughly 640 mud brick
makers and carriers 80 basket carriers
250 Stone Cutters 1500 Stone
Transporters 200 boat Sailors 600 Stone
lifters and 1500 Craftsmen as well as
auxiliary workers
the only problem was that once the stone
robbers removed the outside Limestone
casing the pyramid fell apart
what happens when the Pharaoh died
the funeral of the king is never shown
in release that decorated his pyramid
complex for this we need to look at
burial scenes from the tombs of the
king's official which kind of give us a
nice general idea
the king in his coffin was carried on a
beer overcome with sadness some people
fell to the ground pulled at their
clothing threw dirt on their heads
weeping and wailing the Widow and
professional mourners followed the
coffin along with the embalmer and
Priests
the coffin was loaded on a barge to
Voyage from the East Bank to the pyramid
Harbor on the West Bank of the Nile
immediately upon reaching the necropolis
the pharaoh's body was taken to the tent
of purification
here the body was richly purified and
its viscera removed
then it was taken to the nearby pure
place of wrapping or the mortuary
Workshop there it was packed with salts
to desiccate it oiled and wrapped
the whole process lasted anywhere from
70 to 272 days now the pharaoh's body
was ready to function on another plane
of existence
oxen pulled the pharaoh's mummified body
in its coffin on a sled accompanied by
the funeral Entourage
the procession to the pyramid probably
included all of the Furnishings food and
drink needed for the afterlife this is
only a guess because no burial
assemblage remains intact from Old
Kingdom pyramids
at the pyramid the priest performed the
coming fourth at the voice in vocation
to summon the King to partake of the
offerings
this was followed by offering rituals
that included water incense cloth and
food
the opening of the mouth ritual was
likely performed to allow the king to
breathe eat and speak in the afterlife
once inside the pyramid passages the
coffin was then slid and dragged towards
the burial chamber
it was placed at the large Stone
sarcophagus and the lid to the
sarcophagus was lowered
The Architects of the Great Pyramid
conceived of several different barriers
to protect the burial of the king
once the granite sarcophagus received
the king's body workers lowered three
heavy stones to block access to the
burial chamber
workers then lowered three five ton
blocks of granite to seal the lower end
of the ascending passage from the
descending Passage
with only the light from their crude oil
lamps the Workman exited the grand
Gallery through the service shaft a
28-foot wide tunnel that descended
almost vertically through the guts of
the pyramid the workmen slipped down the
tunnel and emerged into the descending
package
only to crawl their way up and out of
the pyramid presumably with a sigh of
relief
so much for those scenes in Hollywood
movies of all the workers trapped in
eternity inside the pyramid
once the King was buried within the
pyramid the activity did not cease the
mortuary Temple served as the deified
king's Eternal Palace the valley Temple
was its Gateway
priests performed daily and nightly
rituals inside the mortuary Temple and
on its roof
priests opened the statue shrines and
presented cloth sacred oil and recited
the sacred formula to the king's statues
another priest unveiled cleaned dressed
and adorned the Royal statues incense
was lit
priests performed the opening of the
mouse ceremony before the statues then
the offering ceremony took place and the
ritual meal was concerned
these daily rituals assured that the
continuation of the King's life force
since this life force provided for the
living a cult service to the King was a
cult service for everyone
pyramids continue to Captivate Us today
as living monuments of an ancient
civilization with rudimentary tools and
great engineering know-how the ancient
Egyptians built these massive cenotaphs
for their kings
this was not idle labor
the ancient Egyptians saw the pyramids
as Resurrection machines that aided the
Divine King's Eternal Union with the sun
and the heavens and in so doing the king
guaranteed the Perpetual order of Egypt
and the eternal life of those who served
him
[Music]